(soft piano music)
- [Narrator] We are the paradoxical ape:
bipedal, naked, large-brained,
long the master of fire,
tools, and language,
but still trying to understand ourselves,
aware that death is inevitable
yet filled with optimism.
We grow up slowly.
We hand down knowledge.
We empathize and deceive.
We shape the future from our shared
understanding of the past.
CARTA brings together experts
from diverse disciplines
to exchange insights on who we are
and how we got here,
an exploration made possible
by the generosity of humans like you.
(lively music)
(upbeat music)
- Okay, so in this version
of This Is Your Life,
we are gonna start and we're gonna take it
in order of the speakers.
And so that means, Alyssa, can you come up
and regale us with some answers? (laughs)
- Hopefully. (laughs)
- So one of things you spoke about was
the problems with meat production
in terms of the impact
on planetary health.
And so we've got a couple
questions about that.
What about bioengineered
meat for the future?
Do you think this could help
both with what it does in terms of saving
the amount of methane produced
as well as reducing health risks?
- That's one easy.
Yes, absolutely, test
tube meat all the way.
I really, I'm a huge fan
and I teach a lot of this information
to my graduate students.
We're making unbelievable strides
in terms of actually being able
to synthetically, laboratory,
produce meat in a laboratory.
And a lot of animal rights activists
are also very pleased with this
because it is ethically produced meat.
It is sustainable.
I think that we have
some cognitive barriers
we might need to get past
in terms of thinking about
growing our hamburgers
in a petri dish, but it is possible.
So yes, that is actually,
there are big strides being
made in that direction.
- So one of the things that that does
if you have people
retaining their original,
their (mumbles) desire for meat,
it maintains that whole system.
I think you envisage, though,
a possibility of a world
without meat eating at all.
Could you talk about what you think
the role of vegetarianism and veganism is
now and for the future?
- I can.
It's a very, (laughs), I try to dance
very carefully along that line
but Richard just brought me right over
to this big debate.
So this is actually a
very contentious debate
amongst clinicians and nutritionists
and nutritional anthropologists, actually.
And eaters at large.
So I think that there is,
I don't envision a world, personally,
I can talk about myself.
As a nutritional anthropologist,
I don't see a world in which
we are no longer eating meat,
but I also, I think it's a numbers game.
So the numbers that I
produced were from 2017
and I think that most of us
by the demographers' projections
in terms of what the global population
will be by 2050, so I do think
that those projections
with the current state
of factory farming and
food production in general
are not sustainable.
So I think that we are
making a lot of strides
in terms of the way that meat is being,
so the way that our animals are being
treated and fed, and
the way that meat itself
is being processed.
And this is actually moving
out of the developing world.
So the US, it's actually pretty good
internationally speaking
and we're now doing a lot of work
in the developing world with small scale
non-industrial populations
in terms of how they are
treating their livestock.
so this is a global pattern
and something that the UN has been putting
a lot of money and energy into addressing.
In terms of vegetarianism in general,
those numbers are on the
rise globally as well,
so meat eating is going up
but so are people who,
in the post-industrialized
West in particular
you have a big shift to
vegetarianism and veganism,
so you see a switch.
So the developing world
is eating more meat
which is actually the
majority of the world
in terms of population size,
and those in the post-industrialized West
are eating more plants.
And this also, in terms of sustainability,
the whole farm-to-table movement
has really taken off,
and if you're interested there's a lot
of really interesting information
available on the internet
about vertical farming
and about shipping containers
that are now very popular in big cities
like Los Angeles, San Francisco, New York,
where you have indoor
kind of hydroponic growing
in these shipping containers
that are outside in the parking lots
of these eateries.
So it really is farm-to-table.
They're just micro-farms
in shipping containers.
(audience laughing)
- So if you envisage a world
in which meat eating is greatly reduced,
then what are you doing to,
well, let's say men.
Because...
(laughing)
Male chimpanzees eat
more meat than females
and male humans eat more
meat than female humans.
Are you challenging our
evolutionary psychology
in a major way here?
And where do you think the
sex difference comes from?
- Hmm.
Well first I would like to say, I,
I hope that I am not doing
anything intentionally
to men or women or anyone.
I think that's a very interesting question
and one I will try to handle.
Hmm.
I think that the old adage,
you are what you eat, I mean,
this comes from somewhere, right?
This is a concept that is
not foreign to any of us
and I think that humans have a very,
it's not something we talked about today,
but humans have a very emotional response
to the food that they eat.
There are also a lot of cultural practices
and ritual practices that accompany food.
I mean, we didn't talk at all today
about cuisine or dietary
differences around the world.
So there's a lot more to be said,
and I think that we're trending
into that part of this with that question.
But I think that particularly,
clearly all the men in this room
are confident enough in their masculinity
that I don't think that
it is at all tethered
to eating meat.
So that is how I will
answer that question.
All the men in my life
don't need to eat meat.
(audience laughing)
(applauding)
- All right, you can't beat that.
So let's go to something else.
- Thank you! (laughs)
- Here's a question.
What do you think of Gary Taubes' work
suggesting it's refined carbohydrates
and not dietary fat
that cause the diseases
you mentioned?
- I think that's very interesting work,
and if I had been asked,
I have a lot to say about
plant foods as well,
probably more to say about plant foods
than I do about the nutritional
significance of meat.
I do think that refined foods in general
are highly problematic
for nutritional reasons.
I think a lot of this has to do
with additives in addition to
just refined carbohydrates.
So I think it's very promising work.
I think it's very interesting,
and I think that we're
asking the same questions.
What is good for our bodies to eat?
What are we adapted to eat?
We're asking the same questions
we've been asking for decades and decades,
but our methods are becoming
more elegant and refined.
So I think I'm still waiting
for more information to come,
but whoever penned that question,
I'm more than happy to talk to you
in more detail about some of
that specific work afterward
because I'm really very interested
in refined carbs as well.
- So finally, we have a question
that comes straight out of the
Salk Institute, as it were.
The enzyme for decomposing Neu5Gc,
when did it get lost and why?
And is it there in other meat eaters?
- Ooh.
Maybe I can ask Ajit Varki to come up
and answer that question.
So the CMAH gene was lost
two--
- About two million.
- Approximately two million years ago.
So what we know, that was
a very complicated slide
and as I said before, I did
my postdoc in Ajit's lab
but I did a very small portion
of a very large and important study.
I mostly just did the lyophilizer
and drove to local dairies
and got all the dairy to analyze.
But it's a really important study
and the reason the study is important,
the reason everything
coming out of the Varki lab
is really important is because
as a scientist, I like
many different vectors.
So if you can get evidence
from many different lines,
okay, all right, now
we're saying something.
And what's really interesting
about the Neu5Gc case is it doesn't matter
what lens you're using.
It doesn't matter if you're
using animal modeling.
It doesn't matter if you're looking,
it really doesn't matter.
All the evidence, all the
arrows are pointing to this.
So the evolutionary story,
which I did not say in
my one little slide,
we lost this gene.
So you find Neu5Gc in pretty
much, almost every animal.
You do not find it in us
other than what we are eating.
So that's where the metabolic
incorporation comes in.
So we lost the ability to synthesize this,
this particular gene, approximately
two million years ago.
So it is very much integral to this story
of meat eating.
So how and when our
species started eating meat
and what the metabolic consequences are
of that consumption, they're important.
So whether it's at the cellular level,
whether you're dealing
with animal modeling,
whether you're in the Varki lab like I was
lyophilizing cheese, all of it
is part of this big story of humans
and their history of meat eating.
- Thank you very much, Alyssa.
(audience applauding)
Rebecca, are you willing to come
and answer some questions? (laughs)
She is shaking her head,
but that's not the way the game works.
(laughing)
Okay.
- Okay.
- So, (laughs) you're looking nervous.
You're not confident in your masculinity.
- (laughing) No!
(audience laughing)
- Okay, so we have a question
that actually came in
from the streaming world
and it is about the female hunters.
So the question is about the age
and fertility status.
Do they have a special
age and fertility status?
Are they generally older?
Are they pregnant?
Any characterization?
- Yeah.
So women hunt throughout their lives.
When they're girls
they hunt very small lizards,
little lizards called winyjikiti
and they're on the rocks
and you turn over the rocks
and look for the little.
This is specialized kid activity
hunting for these little lizards.
As they get older, they shift toward
hunting for the monitor lizards,
but when women are in their sort of teen
and reproductive years,
they split their time between
hunting monitor lizards,
hunting winyjikiti in the rocks,
and picking fruit and doing a lot
of more sedentary activities.
This is because babies are heavy,
and they're slow, and you wanna go hunting
and you have all these kids with you
and they complain, it's boring,
they wanna go hunt
winyjikiti in the rocks.
So you hunt with them for a while
or you hunt for a while,
and then you gotta go back
and do things with the kids.
So when women are younger
and they're lookin' after the kids more,
they'll be doing less hunting.
And as you become older, indeed,
as a post-menopausal woman,
you become almost a specialized
small-animal hunter.
- Hunter.
- Not a specialized small-animal.
- Yeah.
- I almost said that, didn't I?
(laughing)
- No, no, that was good.
Okay, all right.
So here's another
question about the women,
about the ecology of the situation.
The question is, is it possible
that the willingness of the Martu to share
is related to the abundance
of the food resource?
And the observation here
is that the women in the photos and videos
looked very well fed,
even maybe overweight.
And so, are they actually consuming
some refined carbohydrates as well?
- I would say yes, that that is correct.
Martu contemporary diet
in the Martu community
ranges between about 30% and 50%.
This was between 2000 and 2010
when I was collecting a lot of this data.
Between about 30% to 50% bush food
and the remainder in the form of food
that's purchased at a little
shop in the community.
It's very expensive to
purchase food in the shop
and people get about, a
very small amount of money
fortnightly from the Australian government
which is basically enough
to supply maybe half the calories.
So they generally end up buying
a lot of white flour and
making bread out of it,
and that's basically
what people subsist on.
So diet, contemporary diet today
is actually quite poor in many respects,
so that's why a lot of
ladies are overweight.
Also we have problems with diabetes
and similar sorts of metabolic issues
that you find in a lot of
indigenous communities.
- So given that, do
you think it's possible
that because they are relatively well off
in that respect, I mean,
from an energy point of view,
that they're more willing to share?
Or do you think that's something
that goes back into times when
they didn't have that resource?
- So, no, it definitely,
as food becomes less
scarce, people share less.
So when everybody has
equal amounts of food,
food is very abundant, there's
less sharing that goes on.
Sharing becomes more and more critical
the less food there is,
and there's great efforts made
to ensure that people who are hungry
don't go hungry.
- So there's efforts made to ensure
that people who are
hungry don't go hungry,
but then the opposite also happens?
That when they have more,
then they make efforts
to keep it all for themselves?
- No, actually, they don't. (laughing)
Most of the time, whenever
there's a large harvest
of something brought in,
it's shared really widely.
Have I just contradicted myself? (laughs)
- Well, maybe they share
equally at all times,
but it sounded as though you were saying
they share more when resources are scarce.
- I think that, yeah,
there's a greater emphasis on ensuring
the equality of food consumption
when food is scarce across individuals,
when there's a lot of asynchrony
in how much each individual has.
- So that's what we all wanna hear,
that people are nice in that way.
Now here's a specific question
about the sort of the
utility of the sharing.
Is more protein available to be given
to nursing mothers?
- Uh,
I would think.
Actually, I don't know the
answer to that question.
I would think the women
would get it themselves
if they needed it.
- But--
- But, no.
There's no special favoring.
- There's, I'm pregnant,
give me more food, or,
there's nothing like that?
- Not that I know of.
- No.
Okay, so here's a slightly wacky question
to end up with.
- Oh no.
(audience laughing)
- Is there any support for the idea
that female involvement
in hunting and gathering
has led to modern female shopping?
- Shopping.
(audience laughing)
Hm.
I'm not sure how to answer that question.
Um,
no.
(audience laughing)
(applauding)
- Thank you so much.
Okay, so those were the humans.
Now let's have the chimps.
And in terms of having the chimps,
I think it would be great
to have Ian and David
come up together, because the questions
are rather similar for the two of them.
And we'll see if they
can do some male bonding
or illustrate some of the more violent
propensities of chimpanzees.
- I'm very low-ranking.
- And I'm old and senescent.
(laughing)
- Okay, so here's a question
that's very specific to Ian and or David.
(laughing)
What is the explanation for why bonobos
eat and hunt less?
Is it correlated with
female social dominance,
testosterone?
Bonobos are genetically
closer to homo sapiens
and may represent
insights into inheritance
against acquired behaviors.
David, do you want to take
the first shot at that?
- Well, I'll answer the,
not quite the last part of the question.
First, they aren't closer to humans.
Both are equally close to
humans phylogenetically,
evolutionarily.
That's a good question,
and I don't think we
really know the answer
other than to say that,
first of all, there is a lot of variation,
as Ian pointed out, among
different chimpanzee communities,
not just different populations or chimps
in different habitats.
So there are chimpanzees who hunt
about as infrequently as bonobos do
as far as we can tell.
But still, a big difference seems to be
that bonobos rarely hunt monkeys.
And in some places,
there are no observations
of bonobos hunting monkeys at all.
It's only recently that people
have started to report some from LuiKotale
in the DRC, for example,
and one other site now.
And that might have something to do
with the fact that bonobo males,
their behavioral repertoire
and their social strategies
are quite different from
those of male chimpanzees.
They occasionally form
coalitions with each other
but they don't form
alliances with each other.
If they do, it's much more likely
to be with a female than,
or if they do, it's with
a female, not a male.
And there are differences
in the power balance
between the sexes,
and it might contribute to simply
less inclination on the part of males
to take the risks involved in hunting.
But we don't really know the answer yet.
- I'd like to also add that
we don't necessarily
wanna equate aggression
with hunting as well.
I see it as hunting monkeys is foraging.
And, I mean, it looks awful to us
because they're tearing
little monkeys apart,
but work from Engogo and a little bit
of the work that I have done
have demonstrated that
there's some decoupling
of chimp aggression, testosterone,
and hunting behaviors,
so it's complicated.
- Yeah.
There's actually some very nice data
that Marissa Sobolewski
collected at Engogo
showing that when males, male chimpanzees
go on boundary patrols,
so this is intercommunity aggression,
testosterone levels go up.
And in fact, they go up before males
set out on a patrol, as if somehow
they're anticipating doing this.
She didn't find the same
difference with hunting.
So no increase in testosterone
associated with hunting.
- So you spoke about the differences
between bonobos and chimps
in the way that they hunt.
Could you just give a little bit more
of a description about the
way chimpanzees do hunt?
For instance, do they go on hunts
to look for opportunities to find monkeys
or is it all the result of running
into monkeys by chance?
And then when they do run
into monkeys, what happens?
Ian, do you want to take the first--
- Sure.
The answer, of course,
because they're chimpanzees,
is that it varies.
And I think that's one of
the big take home messages
from this symposium is that
we should move away from talking
about chimps writ large
and talk more about chimps
in different communities
and understanding why we see
the differences that we do.
So at Tai and at Engogo,
the chimps do appear to
go specifically on patrols
or in search of red colobus monkeys.
They go silent.
Although they're in the
middle of their territory,
they're making a beeline
for where the monkeys are,
and they definitely seem
to be searching for them.
At Gombe, Kanyawara, and elsewhere,
it does not seem to be the case.
It's definitely more as though
they are on, they're
moving from one fruit tree
to the next, and they
may take a slight detour
if they hear monkeys
but it doesn't seem like
they're really moving
specifically to find them.
Then I can talk about Gombe in particular
about what happens when a hunt occurs.
It's usually there's
a period of time when,
it's usually the males
gather together underneath the monkeys
and they're looking up and
sort of trying to assess.
In my mind, they're trying to assess
whether or not they're
vulnerable individuals,
the juveniles and infants.
And then one or more individual chimps
will rush up into the trees
and chase the monkeys.
It's my impression,
and also I have data to back this up,
that, at least at Gombe,
it certainly seems to be
every chimp for himself.
There does not seem to be
any kind of coordination,
and it's what we call a
byproduct of mutualism
in the sense that each individual
is selfishly trying to get his own monkey
but in doing so, creates chaos
and makes it easier
for other guys to hunt.
And we've actually found evidence
of specific individuals
who are more keen hunters
who sort of catalyze these hunts.
I don't know if you wanna add anything.
- Variation, yes.
The majority of red colobus hunts
that we've seen at Engogo have happened
during these patrols when the chimpanzees
seem to look for monkeys to hunt
and will sometimes go
for a couple of hours
to try to find some.
And then they may find
some and decide not to hunt
because the group is too small
or it's just a bad situation.
And the subject of deferred consumption
came up today with reference to humans
and earlier hominins carrying
parts of butchered
carcasses or entire animals
from one place to another
and then processing them further
and consuming them there.
Chimpanzees don't do that,
except on a very small scale
when they will carry some meat
away from the immediate
location of a hunt.
But I have seen them wait
and patiently follow
a group of red colobus
or simply wait under the monkeys
for an hour or an hour and a half
and then the monkeys do something stupid.
(laughing)
They put themselves in a bad position
and the chimps are up
and after them like that.
And then also, I would agree,
it's very difficult to see
on most occasions whether there is any
real coordination among
the individuals involved.
Occasionally it's easy.
So, I once remember
seeing Mingus at Engogo
who was not the best at capturing monkeys
but he was the least afraid
of taking on adult male red colobus,
and he went up into a tree
and got underneath this group of monkeys
who were stationary above the chimps.
And there were 18 other
adult male chimpanzees
on the ground below him
and he sat there for maybe 15, 20 minutes
waiting for anyone else
to come up to join him,
and none of them did so eventually
he came down, and no hunt.
But at other times,
it's just chaos, to us.
But the chimpanzees, as Ian said,
are at least very good
at playing off of each other
and recognizing when someone else
has done something that puts a monkey
in a vulnerable position,
and then making an effort to pick it off.
- Just to change topic
a little bit from this.
You've already spoken about
your skepticism about
any kind of relationship
between violence towards members
of their own species and hunting.
However, there are a couple
of questions about this.
And let me put it this way,
to what do you attribute the fact
that chimpanzees are
both violent and hunters
while bonobos are not?
And that in humans,
there's lots of evidence
showing that there is a relationship
between hunting and violence?
So Keith Autobon found that the groups
in which you had a higher percentage
of the diet coming from hunting
were more likely to be involved in war.
Any explanations for these correlations?
- Is this a question
coming from the crowd, or--
- It's coming from...
(audience laughing)
- Yeah, uh-huh. (laughing)
David, you take this one.
- Okay, where do I start?
We have a limited amount of time here.
Bonobos are not quite as non-violent
as the popular literature would have it,
but there do seem to be
some real differences
between bonobos and
chimpanzees on that score.
Bonobos generally are afraid of,
hostile towards neighbors,
although there are intriguing reports
of members of presumably
different bonobo communities
encountering each other
and having peaceful
and even friendly
interactions with each other,
which would not happen in chimpanzees.
And bonobos are not known to engage
in chimpanzee patrol-like behavior,
going to look for opportunities
to make attacks on neighbors.
And whether that really contributes to,
in itself, to the difference
in hunting frequencies
and in particular, differences
in the hunting monkeys,
again, it's a good question
and it's hard to be certain.
When it comes to the
human ethnographic record,
I happen to be teaching, co-teaching
a course now with a
couple of my colleagues
called The Anthropology of War,
and I could probably go on far too long
about the questions about the variation
in the reported frequency of warfare
among historically documented
hunter-gatherer groups, for example.
But I don't think it's that simple,
that you can just look
at a few figures and say,
oh, well, this society hunted more
than that one and also
they engaged in war more.
In fact, there are some problems
with the literature on the subject
of variation in, however we define it,
and I'm begging a big question there
in the frequency of war
among hunter-gatherers.
- I should just add that with
regard to bonobos hunting,
we still don't have fundamental data
on the rate at which they're encountering
potential prey, so that's
one possible explanation.
- Okay, I'm duly put in my place.
(audience laughing)
And I'm gonna resort to the final question
which raises a question
about conservation.
The question is, do indigenous people
living where chimps hunt primates
also hunt and eat primates themselves?
- Certainly around Gombe there is a taboo
against eating primates,
particularly chimpanzees.
So that's good.
However, we do have problems
with traps that are set for ungulates
that chimpanzees will potentially step in
and get caught.
It's not nearly as big as a problem
as it is at Kibale, but...
- When we come to humans,
then we really encounter variation.
And there's tremendous cultural variation
even in the same parts of Africa
in terms of people's
interest in eating bush meat,
as it's called.
And in some places, chimpanzees
and gorillas are food,
and it's been a huge conservation issue
in parts of Central and West Africa.
In Kibale, for example,
fortunately, at least until recently,
people living around this national park
did not regard primates as food.
That has started to change
initially with baboons,
which cause a lot of problems
because they raid people's crops.
And also, they are
legally vermin in Uganda
so it's not illegal to kill them,
but unfortunately we do now have
at least one case and possibly more
of people going after
chimpanzees to get meat.
Hopefully that's not going to continue.
- Thank you very much, David and Ian.
(audience applauding)
Jill, we welcome you.
Oh, you've got another question?
You're going to ask me a question, or--
- I brought my own.
- Okay.
All right.
(audience laughing)
Is it a good one?
- I don't know.
I didn't look at it.
- Okay, all right.
Well, I wanted to start off
with just a question clarifying some
of the methodological issues.
If you could observe male and female
Fongoli chimps equally,
do you think that the
amount of female hunting
would increase, decrease,
or stay the same?
- Oh, I think it would
definitely increase.
So, like I said, we
have focal male subjects
that we follow from when they get up
in the morning to when
they go to sleep at night.
We're taking data every five minutes.
There are times of the year when we never,
they never leave our sight
'cause we have really great visibility.
The females are there and it's
a very cohesive community,
so we're rarely without females
but again, I'm not targeting them.
The thing about the bush baby hunting
is that it is audible,
and so you can hear the sound of the tool
hitting into the tree branch.
And so when I hear that, or if I see it,
I abandon my male and I go observe
whoever is hunting at the time.
So we've got some good
information on females
but I think that we're really
underestimating what they're doing, mm-hm.
- Okay, so if the females are going
to be doing even more,
do you already have a sense
of the way this is inherited?
Is there any possibility
that the daughters
of the mothers who hunt a lot with sticks,
with tools are doing it more themselves?
- That's a great question,
and something we're looking at now.
So we have enough data so we can look at
individuals as they were infant,
juveniles, adolescents,
and now even some adults,
and look at the behavior of their mother.
So, you know, I would expect
that these two top high-ranking females
that hunt a lot might have kids
that are good hunters as well,
and I would expect to
see some sex differences
like has been found at
Gombe with termite fishing.
But we're just kind of in the midst
of analyses right now.
Just qualitatively, there are
some families, for example.
I didn't mention Lucile, but she's also
a prominent bush baby hunter
and her kids seem especially precocious
in terms of hunting,
and so I would expect to
see some differences there
but I'm just, you know,
I can't say for sure yet.
- Okay, so meat theft, you said,
is not very common in the Fongoli chimps.
So there's a question about why that is.
Is it because they all hunt
and so they're all getting lots of meat?
Or do they all hunt because
theft is relatively rare?
- I mean, I would kinda say the latter.
Again, it's something
that we're looking at.
I think there's incentive to hunt.
One of the hypotheses that I'm looking at
is because of that skewed sex ratio,
it could be that males are tolerant
as a form of mating strategy.
That's just one of the hypotheses.
So do they share more with females
that are in estrus or
with certain females?
I will say that preliminary data
shows that there's not the support
for the meat for sex hypotheses.
But that is definitely a
hypotheses we're looking at.
So does this have to do,
can this skewed sex ratio at Fongoli
explain what I see as male tolerance?
And again, we find some support for it
with the preliminary evidence,
so I expect it to, hopefully, stand up.
Well, not hopefully, but perhaps it will.
But there are a number of different ideas.
I guess one is that,
there do seem to be some trends
that you see in West African chimps
where there might be some differences
compared to East African subspecies
and so you see these grouping behaviors
at Tai where you have a lot
of males and females together.
You see the same thing at Gombe.
So that's also something that
we're taking into account.
Or could it be a subspecies difference?
- With the sharing patterns,
did you say that they share more
with unrelated individuals
than their own offspring?
- They do.
- Could you say a little
bit more about that?
That seems like a
particularly odd thing to do.
- Sure, yeah.
So yeah, the females obviously
haven't read the literature.
So we expected, you know,
a couple of hypotheses that we tested,
one would be the kin selection hypothesis.
You expect to share with your kids,
and we were really surprised, (laughing)
I don't know why I find it funny,
but we were really surprised
to find that that was not the case.
And not only did they
share with adult males,
but they also shared with adult females.
And so that's definitely something
that we're looking into.
We have a bigger sample size
but I believe our initial analyses
was of over 270 dyadic events.
And so, yeah, that was really interesting.
Males share with females
as well as other adult males.
And again, the meat for sex hypothesis
has not been supported.
So kids, you know,
offspring do get a share
but that is still surprising to me,
that they don't get more than they do.
- So one final question
about the hunting strategy.
Do they already know when
they're approaching a tree
if there's a galago in there
when they stop poking with sticks?
Or is it just all exploratory?
- That's a really good question.
that's something that we're exploring now.
So I have actually someone
studying galagos at my site.
She just, no, she'll start next week.
We've been trying to study them.
We have various ways of doing it.
But one of the big questions is
the availability and counter rate,
so I think it's opportunistic
but they do revisit sites
where they've captured galagos before.
It seems to me there's a
definite age difference.
So adults will abandon
a site quite quickly,
and so they may go up and
just look in and leave it.
They may go up, make a tool,
stab around in there for a while.
I don't know if you
could see here doing that
on the film, but they'll smell it
and sometimes even taste the tip.
And adults will abandon sites
sometimes quite quickly,
and then immature individuals will come
and just keep at it for
10 minutes or 15 minutes.
So I assume that they can assess
whether or not there's a galago there
fairly quickly, but we're not sure.
So we have different methods.
We have a borescope that we've been using
which is what a plumber uses
to look into drain pipes,
and so (laughing) I've been
having a field assistant
climb trees and use a borescope
to try to see what's going on.
He doesn't really like that very much.
(audience laughing)
That's only worked out
so, you know, it's okay,
but now we're really
doing a systematic studies
of the bush baby themselves,
'cause we think a lot of what's going on
at least in terms of the
tool-assisted hunting,
and I didn't talk about it
but it's a very focused season,
I call it bush baby season,
that probably has to do a lot
with the galago behavior itself.
- I think it's just great
that these new discoveries
are still coming out, and it means
that students should be
going out to the field
finding new places to do the kind of work
that Jill has done.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
Jim, I think it's time
for me to turn over.
- I guess I'll launch in.
Margaret, are you still here?
Hi, Margaret!
Got some questions for you.
(audience chuckling)
We've got a very specific one
and a very general one,
so this will kind of span the range.
- What fun, yes.
- So which you want first?
(laughing)
I'll give you the specific one.
Do colobine monkeys fit the C3, C4 model
that you presented given their specialized
digestive systems and their
end stage digestion process?
- They do, actually.
They don't eat C4.
So they are actually
going only after C3 leaves
or there is one that goes after lichens
and those happen to be C3.
So yes, it's all C3.
- Now for the slightly bigger picture.
There's a theory that associates
the consumption of meat not only
with all the behavioral traits
that made us human but specifically
with the encephalization,
the evolution of larger brains
in humans and other primates.
Is this supported by the evidence?
An association between
the consumption of meat
and meat byproducts playing a role
in encephalization.
- I wanna say that I happen to agree
completely with Richard's
point about the fat.
The problem with fat is that it is
not gonna record in the appetite.
It is not picked up.
So the C3, C4 that I'm
seeing cannot be fat.
There must be some meat eating going along
because you don't see it.
So the question is,
do I think that has anything
to do with encephalization.
I think the fat does,
because I think there's a lot of energy.
And also, the very first tools we see,
there are fillets,
I'm not gonna deny there are fillets,
but there are a lot of pounding tools.
And when I looked at the Hadza data
and I was watching them,
of course, they're pounding all the time
because they're eating baobab seeds
and they're pounding.
And I thought, hm.
I mean, why couldn't you just pound a bone
and get the marrow out of it?
Also I should say, at Koobi Fora
where Henry Bunn was working
for a very long time looking at cut marks
and crushed bone, what we noticed,
or he noticed, I should
say, and pointed out to me
is that every hippo jaw has a divot
taken out of it right where
there is a big fat pad.
So I found that extremely interesting
because the energy from fat
would actually feed a growing brain.
And as Bob Martin always said,
the female will grow the
largest offspring she can
with the largest brain across anything.
Well you increase the energy enormously,
then I can see where you could
actually end up with the mother
producing a larger-brained offspring
to a limit of what her body can tolerate.
- I always like to make
things more complicated--
- Of course you do.
- Than they need to be.
- I know you do.
I wrote a paper with you.
(laughing)
- Woo!
Well.
- You shouldn't have said that to me
until afterward.
- And on that note.
- Yes. (laughing)
- As I understand it,
there's sort of two ways to look
at the role that diet changes
and that access to meat could
play in encephalization,
and fat would be included.
In one version, obtaining
this great nutrient source,
perhaps only great once it's cooked
but nevertheless is a
great nutrient source,
enables us to grow a larger brain.
The other version is that obtaining
this easily digested nutrient source
enables us to shrink our guts,
and when our guts shrink
we're not spending as much energy
metabolizing food and
so we have this surplus.
The surplus energy is then available
to build the brain with there.
Can you tease those apart at all?
- Yeah.
There was a hypothesis by Leslie Allo
that you trade what's going on in the gut
with the brain.
And I have to go back
to Bob Martin yet again
and say that what he was pointing out
was that you increase energy in,
you decrease the gut, and it
also can increase the brain.
So the two are going together
but the way he liked to point it out,
and I always thought
it made a lot of sense,
is that it's going through the mother.
And so it's not so much
that the animal themself,
but it makes the sense
in terms of reproduction
because it's going through the mother.
So I definitely think
the two are connected.
You decrease the guts.
You don't have to spend as much energy
in processing your food.
You have the energy left over,
and it's usually more
easily digested energy
whether it be fat or cooked meat.
And yes, you can.
I think it's always made sense to me
that that's the way it worked.
- Okay, thank you.
(audience applauding)
Briana.
There were a couple of
questions along the line,
and you can see where this is coming from,
a couple of questions along the line of
given these ideas about
bone marrow availability,
and actually Margaret touched on this,
but what sort of actualistic data
do you have on scavenging
for the inside of bones?
And any work going on and
bone marrow availability?
- So any actualistic work going on?
That's a good question.
I don't think there has been as much
actualistic work done on bone marrow.
As far as thinking
about the fossil record,
though, I think percussion marks
were only recognized starting in 1988,
and they're, I think, in some ways
harder to recognize on
fossils than cut marks are.
And I have a really fun database
that I try to keep up on
actually from the early Stone Age
all of the sites that have evidence
for butchering marks,
including both cut marks
and percussion marks.
And I think the percussion mark,
I think that percussion marks
are under recognized and under reported.
So I'm really enjoying the conversations
about the importance of marrow
because I think that's pretty significant.
- Okay.
There's a couple of related ones.
I'll just sort of ask them together
because they'll play off of each other.
You were working, and for good reason
you're working in a place
that was a felid dominated environment,
but how would the presence
of other scavengers,
in particular hyenas,
affect the availability
of scavenged resources?
And is there any way to then tie in
the availability of scavenged resources
to the absolute population
that would be supportable?
A hominin population.
- Yeah.
Okay, so the first question about
how do hyenas, what
difference do hyenas make.
So hyenas have very specialized dentition
for basically crushing bone
and so once you get hyenas,
once you get large populations of hyenas
they clean up the African ecosystems.
And so there are much fewer
scavenging opportunities
when hyenas are involved.
So I don't know if that fully answers
the first question potentially.
And the second question was about
how would that make a difference
for the overall hominin population
that could be supported.
Is that right?
- Mm-hm.
- So I'm not sure we have good ways
to model that and think about that,
partially because I think
hominins, like carnivores,
were both pretty rare
generally on the landscape,
certainly much more rare than herbivores.
And so I don't think we can confidently
extrapolate carnivore populations
are particularly like the proportions
of felids versus hyenas in the past
necessarily just from the fossil record.
The fossil record is all we have.
But I think that certainly
in an area where felids were dominant,
and there were three different genera
of saber tooth felids that
were around in the past
at the times that we're talking about
when hominins were first eating meat.
And there have been
propositions or hypotheses
that it's actually scavenging potentially
from saber tooth kills,
at least one of those genera
probably was a solitary felid
more like leopards today
may have stashed their kills in trees,
and so those may have been
really profitable scavenging
opportunities for hominins.
They're a little bit harder to model
since we don't have saber
tooths around today.
- Yeah, I'd like to follow up on that
because I know that there was a suggestion
that some of the saber tooths
were specialists on very large animals
and the whole saber tooth thing.
There was a time when it was believed
that their teeth were so brittle
that all they could really do
was kind of run in, slit the jugular,
and I think there was even a suggestion
that they then lapped up the blood
and didn't really get
into the carcass at all,
but otherwise that they
would just eat the gut
and leave the skeletal
system complete intact.
What's the status of that idea?
Or do we know more about saber tooths now?
- So, we will soon.
I'm doing a research project actually
with a member of the audience,
Jennifer Parkinson, right now studying,
restudying a saber tooth
den collection in Texas,
a Pleistocene den where we have
lots of saber tooth fossils
and we have lots of baby mammoths.
So we think, or at least the idea is
that saber tooths are kind of dragging
these baby mammoths,
and some adults as well,
or mastodons, back to this den.
And so we see tooth marks
on some of these bones
so I think that the idea
that saber tooths were
only using their teeth
potentially for killing and not
for eating at all, and that they would
leave a lot of the carcass left over,
I'm not sure about that.
They certainly were flesh
specialists, though,
so they did not have the kind
of jaw and tooth capabilities
that even probably modern lions have
in order to break up bones,
particularly of really big animals.
So from really big kills of saber tooths
especially if they were solitary,
not social like lions were,
I think that's a really
good scavenging opportunity.
- And when did lions come on the scene?
- I think about somewhere between two
and three million years ago,
so modern lions, leopards
are basically around
in some form by this time.
- But the earliest stage,
you know, the sort of three
to four million, no lions--
- Well, or at least not modern lions.
So certainly there were, you know,
things like lions around at that time.
- All right.
A specific question.
And for some reason, I'm not sure
this is the right word,
but I can't remember it.
Fecaliths.
A fossil--
- Coprolite?
- Coprolites, yes.
- Coprolite.
- Yes, yeah.
Well, fecal, you know, stone feces.
(audience laughing)
How far back can coprolites
give information about diet?
- Ooh.
I suspect that coprolites
can give information
about diet as far back
as we can find them.
And I know that there have been coprolite,
at least carnivore coprolites found
in the fossil record, I think,
for the past few hundred thousand years.
I don't know so much about, you know,
human coprolites, but I
think that's an interesting
line of evidence that would, (laughs)
I don't know if we need more of it
but it would be,
I think it's a different and interesting
line of evidence.
But it sounds like there
was more to the question.
- I don't know if this
is a two part question.
I don't know the relationship,
but the other part of this was,
when does the first evidence
of cannibalism appear?
And I assume this is talking
about dietary cannibalism.
- Right.
So the first evidence of cannibalism there
is, I believe it's a fossil skull
from Sterkfontein, a site in South Africa
that's about two million years old
that has butchery marks on it.
So this is kind of one individual
that seems to have decent cut marks on it.
But the first evidence of
more systematic cannibalism
comes in, I believe,
at about 400,000 years
from a site in Spain
where there are hominins
that are butchered
basically in the same way
that animals are butchered at this site.
And so it seems like dietary
or nutritive cannibalism is something
that was rare just
because hominins are rare,
and so you're less likely to find them
and less likely to find
butchery marks on them.
But I would suspect that probably
for the entirety of the
evidence for tool use
in our evolutionary history.
- That's grim.
(laughing)
I'm tempted to ask John
Speth to come up here,
but there's a question here about
would fire be necessary
to make scavenging safe?
When we hear about the bacteria.
And I mention John because he's written
a really nasty paper on
modern human scavenging
or eating, consumption
of raw, rotten meat.
And if any of you have been to Iceland,
I mean, rotten shark is a delicacy
so it is something that gets done.
And I don't know--
- That's a good question.
I think, you know, the evidence
that Margaret talked about in her talk,
or I think it was one of the speakers
talked about with the evidence
for just bacterial growth and other things
that can make scavengable carcasses
dangerous pretty quickly,
I think it really depends on the timing
of access to those carcasses.
So if they're really quite fresh,
I think you just use your nose.
If they smell bad, if they look like
they're disgusting, I suspect
that they wouldn't be as useful
for scavengable resources.
- Okay, so it'd be playing, okay.
- Yeah, potentially.
- Thank you.
- Okay.
(audience applauding)
- Richard.
Since the high temperature
cooking of animal fats
can result in carcinogenic molecules,
could this have been a problem
that would have possibly led to increased
particularly gastrointestinal cancers
during human evolution?
- Well, they'd have been so lucky
to be able to have regular access
to overheated fats, I would think.
It seems to me very much a question
about today's world,
where we've dealt with a tremendous number
of the basic nutritional problems
and we can afford to worry
about the great detail of the costs
that come along with all of the benefits.
The important thing for the hominins
would surely have been what it is
for other primates and for
hunters and gatherers today,
which is getting enough access to energy.
The amount of carcinogenic impact would,
I would have thought, been
definitely extremely small
compared to the benefits
coming from energy.
However, you know, it's fascinating
to think about the possibility
that there has been
some kind of adaptation
to some of the deleterious byproducts
that come from cooking.
So Maillard compounds
is this very complicated
family of compounds that are produced
by the ultimately interaction
of sugars and amino acids,
and they're basically unique
in their concentration
when produced by cooking.
And there is a little bit of
sort of anecdotal evidence
that humans are less susceptible
to the deleterious consequences
of some Maillard compounds
than in other animals.
This is a fascinating area to explore.
- Okay, so you're looking at it, yeah.
- Well, I'm not looking at it.
- Well, no, but I mean you're looking
at the question of whether other people
are looking at it.
- Looking at it.
- Yeah, looking up data for it.
Okay.
When I started grad school,
the story of human
evolution was fairly simple.
There was a grass Australopithecus
and it gave rise to a homo
and then it gave rise to advanced homo
and then here we are.
And we now know that
there's a lot of bushiness
in the family tree.
Do you believe that cooking food
evolved once or more than once
in the hominin lineage?
- Well, believe is a
little strong because,
(audience laughing)
this is not a religion, this is science.
(audience laughs)
- In your opinion, is there
evidence supporting? (laughs)
- So the way I reconstruct it,
you know, there's this conflict
between the biological and
the archeological evidence,
I think of it, and the biological evidence
pushes us to saying that the change
in the shape of the ribs
indicating the smaller gut
that Margaret referred to,
the smaller teeth, the weaker jaw muscles,
a bunch of these anatomical changes
they all happened just this side
of two millions years, let's say.
And so that's the biological evidence.
The archeological evidence
is that fire came in very late.
To me, the fascinating
question about this is
what is gonna resolve it.
And if it turns out that for some reason
we're able to get convinced
that fire really wasn't controlled
prior to, say, half a million years ago
which is very, very (mumbles).
You know, there are sites like
Wonderwerk in South Africa
which has it at a million
and maybe a little bit more.
But if it turns out that fire
was controlled relatively late like that,
then what on earth was responsible
for the gracilization and reduction
of the human digestive
system, if it wasn't cooking?
And to me, what is so interesting
is that nobody has really suggested
what that could be.
The only thing that I can think of
is that there would be
a pretty much 100% focus
on marrow fats, or on fats.
And the reason I say that is,
you've got to go close to 100%,
first of all, that doesn't
take much tooth work
and second,
let's see, where was I?
(laughing)
I'm so excited about it, sorry. (laughs)
- You were pointing out
that thoroughly rotten meat
doesn't take much tooth work either.
- Yes, but that's not the point
that I wanted to make here.
The point I wanted to make is that
as long as the hominins had to resort
sometimes to eating plants,
then they needed to have
the more robust jaws,
the bigger teeth, the bigger guts,
to be able to process them in the mouth
and then ferment them in the colon.
And until you can overcome the need
to eat raw plants at some time,
then I don't see how you can get
to that reduced digestive
system of humans.
So for that reason, it's
just very, very difficult
for me to imagine that the entrance
of the control of fire won't come
up to something around
1.9 million years ago.
But if it doesn't, then, you know,
somebody in the audience
solve that problem.
What did they eat?
- [Audience Member] What about
mechanical processing of food?
- Well, okay.
(laughing)
All right. (laughs)
So what about mechanical
processing of food?
Katie Zink and Dan Lieberman
have said that this would
make it easier to chew.
So the problem I have with that
is that, to my knowledge,
we don't have any examples
from modern hunter-gatherers
of processing of plants,
or pounding, to eat raw.
And it's kind of difficult to imagine
exactly how it is gonna work to eat raw.
I mean, to pound the seeds
and then put them into a,
well, a pot makes it particularly easy
or a damper, you know,
a sort of pancake type of thing
that you can put on the fire.
That's fine.
But what, you reduce this pounding
to something that you can eat as a powder?
And remember that starch grains
are not normally broken down by pounding.
So to the extent that the plant part
is important for producing starch,
which should be very important,
than pounding is gonna be no good.
You need cooking to get the starch
reduced to glucose.
But Rebecca's got a...
- [Rebecca] (mumbles)
Most aboriginal groups
that relied on wild tomatoes
pounded them up, so
they're pounding fruit.
And part of the reason they're pounding up
the fruit is to concentrate the energy
so you can carry it and
keep it long distances.
- Oh, and reducing the water.
- The water, yeah.
And also you can actually get access
to the protein in the
seeds by pounding it.
- Okay, so that sounds great.
But it doesn't sound as though
it would necessarily increase
the net energy value.
- It may not sound at all
to the people in the back.
Let me just repeat,
(laughing)
let me just repeat that
Rebecca was pointing out
that among the people she
works with in Australia
that they pound tomatoes and other fruits
more in order to reduce the water content
and make them more compact
and easier to carry.
- We got other questions here.
Are we allowed to take these?
- [Audience Member]
Baobab seeds are 36% fat
and so when they pound them, they usually,
and Melissa has obviously looked at them
longer than I did, they didn't cook it.
- Okay, so another example
from the Hadza of East Africa.
- [Audience Member] And you do it twice
because of course, you can do it
when the baobab seeds are ripe
and then you do it when the
baboons have pooped it out,
which makes it easier.
- So another ethnographic counterexample
where people are pounding baobab seeds
to access the high fat seed within.
So there are a few examples, then,
(laughing)
and the devil may be in the details
of how widespread they are.
So mechanical processing
is important some places.
Okay.
- My masculinity...
(laughing drowns out speech)
Yeah it's, zooop.
- Well, that's no good.
Are there any human cultures
that have lost fire?
- No.
- Thank you.
(laughing)
Okay.
I don't know if this is,
well, I'll just give you this one.
You can decide whether
or not to address that.
- The question about losing fire,
the question that people
do investigate more often
is whether people have lost the ability
to make fire for themselves.
And there are some claims
that that might have happened,
but it doesn't seem relevant
because they can always get fire
by going to the neighbors.
So basically once you have a population
maintaining fire, then
they can keep it going.
- I saw the movie, Quest For Fire.
- Exactly.
And am I aware that there is something
called the roadkill cookbook?
(audience laughing)
As a model of the origins of the human
predatory pattern, I'm dubious.
(audience laughing)
- It might tie in with running, though.
There are two,
you can either stay here or not.
There are two last questions.
I'm not sure if we really have time
to address them, although they're directed
to all the speakers.
I wanna read them because
I think what they do
is they fit very nicely
into what CARTA is all about.
There's one, obviously
a switch to meat eating
induced a radical change
in digestive systems
underlying genetics.
How did we get from here to there
or from there to here, in any case?
So what are the underlying genetics
involved in the restructuring of the body?
And then a second one is,
I don't know if this is a
mildly aggressive question,
but, it's okay.
Where does your understanding
of nutrition come from?
How much do you consult with nutritionists
and nutritional scientists?
How does it impact your interpretations
or observations if some of
your fundamental beliefs
about nutrition are flawed?
I think that the reason
that I like those questions,
and I'll give you a chance to address it,
but I like those questions
because they both have built into them
this incredible interdisciplinary
transdisciplinary complexity
of understanding this problem.
We've got people who, you know,
who study chimpanzees or who
look at cut marks on bones
and in order to interpret
what they're doing,
we need to know some genetics
and we need to know some nutrition.
There's a lot of fields
that have to come together.
In the normal course of events,
people in these different areas
go to conferences with other people
in their own areas, and
they talk to other people
who study bones or who
study apes or whatever.
CARTA is a really great venue, I think,
that brings together people
from these different specialties.
We probably don't have as wide a net
present in this room or at this symposium
as we could use, but it's still wider
than we normally get.
And we start to try to get
at some of these questions
and put these pieces together.
With that said, how do you interact with,
and this, again, is for all of us.
On the nutrition specifically,
where do you get the interaction
and how much do you try to go for it?
- Nutritional science
is a very funny science.
Marion Nestle--
- Says the guy who works on chimps.
(laughing)
- Marion Nestle is this
very good biochemist
who was invited to do a,
to teach a course something like 20,
maybe 25 years ago, on nutrition
because the department needed it.
She hadn't gone into that area at all.
And she tells a story about how she got
eight textbooks and opened them up
and put them in a row on a desk,
and then saw what everybody said.
And she said, the answers were
just incredibly different.
So there is a real
danger, or there was then,
and even now I think there is a danger
of being able to cherry
pick what results you want.
So having said that, let me
just mention about cooking.
You know, because,
(audience laughing)
well, I mean, look.
The fact is that cooking
is hugely important
for humans, okay?
And so you would think that we would have
a lot of information about
what the impact of cooking is
on the energy value of foods.
And I was astounded
when almost 20 years ago
I started thinking about
the importance of cooking
and I went to the nutritional literature
and it wasn't there.
It was really, really difficult to find.
In our lab, we did the
first-hand experiments
to looking at the impact
of cooking on meat
and its digestibility
and the cost of digestion
associated with it.
And I've just said that you do not have
any data at the moment on the impact on
what I think of as the most important
macronutrient in human
evolution, namely animal fats.
So where do we go for nutritional science?
You have to, very often,
make it up yourself.
- [Alyssa] Can I take a question?
- Alyssa, yes.
I think this will be the last response.
- Oh, this not a very
exciting end to that.
But I think that was a
really important question,
so whoever posed that, thank you.
This is something I struggle with
(laughs) daily, weekly, monthly.
I do a lot of presentations
and a lot of conferencing
with nutritional sciences,
food sciences, chemists.
I do a lot of work with
the nutrition community.
So me personally, I do a lot of work
that is totally embedded in nutrition.
And I blame Margaret for that.
I blame Margaret because
I came to graduate school
here at UCSD, and I wanted to ask
these big, grandiose questions
about how ecology influences
behavior and reproduction
and I was using food as my metric.
And Margaret said, that's great,
but what is in the food?
What are you actually measuring?
And I hadn't thought about that.
I hate to admit this, but I think a lot
of the literature doesn't
really think about that,
particularly the literature as far
as it pertains to human
foraging populations.
And we have people in
here, Kristen Hawkes,
Nick Blurton-Jones and colleagues
who were one of the very first teams
that actually decided to work with
nutritional chemists to figure out
what's in forager foods.
So personally, I do a lot of
work in nutrition sciences.
It's very messy, and I will say
that in the early 2000s when I came back
with wild hods of foods,
no commercial nutrition lab
would take my foods.
So Richard's lab is where I did
all of my analyses of hods of foods
with a fantastic nutrition scientist
named Nancy Lou Conklin-Brittain
who, I think, can beat
the pants off anyone
in terms of thinking about how to
use all of these different methods.
And she will often analyze a food,
a wild food, with four
different laboratory methods
that she's found from all over the world
and figure out where they overlap.
So I think it depends on who you're asking
in terms of our
relationship with nutrition,
but I think that as a
discipline in general,
particularly for those of us
that are talking about food in general,
it's very important to think about
the nutritional components.
And there are people, John
Speth is in here somewhere,
who really do this and do it very well.
But there's not enough.
So graduate students,
go learn nutritional chemistry please.
It will serve you well, I promise.
(audience applauding)
- I was supposed to
spend about five minutes
summarizing this symposium,
and I cleverly let the questions go on
to pretty much chew up that time.
Because I think that
answering your questions
is a lot more important than listening
to what I might come up with.
I will just say that the genesis
for this symposium came from the fact
that I work at a savanna
chimpanzee study site
where we have red colobus, and our chimps
don't seem to eat them.
And so I was presented with this puzzle
about chimpanzee hunting.
And the reason that we work there
is to try to gain insight
into the conditions that early hominins
might have had.
And so I started trying to
pull all of this together
and contacting smart people
who know more about both modern hunting
and about chimpanzees than I do.
And I've been tremendously pleased
and learned quite a lot in the process.
I hope you have as well.
So that's my summary as far as it goes.
I'd now like to give you to Ajit Varki.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you so much.
I'd like to thank the CARTA team
and all those who made
the symposium possible,
the chairs, the featured speakers,
sponsors and supporters, and the audience
for attending and for the great questions.
A really exciting and
interesting symposium.
I'd like to remind you that we have
an upcoming symposium, and you
can look them up on the web.
I look forward to seeing
you at the next one.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
(upbeat music)